[Music]
is it too late now to say hey babe
yeah
is it too late to say hey babe now there
it is
babe I almost didn't make it today what
happened I was boxing with Sergio Chacon
AKA uh the Puerto Rican freaking
um we have Luis Gomez known as the
freaking weekend baby about to have some
fun shout out Kelly uh we call Lewis our
friend Luis Gomez uh the Puerto Rican
rattlesnake we call Sergio chicon the
Puerto Rican garden snake uh because
he's into flowers and plants and um
Sergio who's more dangerous that's oh a
battle of the snakes I'll tell you what
Sergio is more of a oh
if Lewis just had to box Sergio will
probably win Serge if Sergio Chacon
versus Louis Gomez I still I think that
Sergio is more technical fighter but I
think Lewis Lewis would um uh fight
dirty and I think he'd start to bite
okay yeah so um but I um so we were we
were we were uh training today shout out
overthrower boxing um uh which I forgot
to venmo Sergio his pay and I'll
continue to forget for the next week so
we
training does that mean you're training
for something or do you just when you're
boxing you call exercising training I
call right when I'm boxing training
because you're trying to get better at
boxing so that's training for boxing
right but for the idea of boxing for the
idea of boxing I love a box I was I'm
trying to get better at it and and yes
I'm not looking to fight or anything
like that could you fight Jake Paul
I could find Jake Paul and I will fight
Jake Paul and that's a direct challenge
out to the camera Jake Paul if you're
watching let me know that you are I'm
I'm challenging you to a fight
I mean our The Babe Nation will be there
and I mean you train hard with Sergio
and sponsor you I'd like my name on your
shorts 100 on the ass though 100 and
honestly I I have total of faith in you
that will be our hey babe live you guys
did taste buds live a huge success which
we'll talk about but hey babe live will
be I fight Jake Paul yeah
um so so he told me he said listen you
know we're doing a little uh little pad
work or whatever he goes but I want to
do some live shots
he goes so you know I let's box let's
let's let's train he goes I'm telling
you I'm it's gonna be this this combo
and then it's ending with a hook to the
left he told me two or three times a
hook to the left is coming at you and
we're going full speed are you wearing a
head here no okay because he said we're
just like in training mode but he said
I'm you know I want you to really react
in real time but I'm telling it's a hook
to the left yeah he said it to me two
three times my brain two or three times
said it's a hook to the right it's just
converted as a whole it just I just
continuously set it to hook to the right
right so
we're doing it I said here we go it's
coming hooked to the right Blind Side he
of course throws a hook to the left I at
the last second realized it got out of
the way duck down it hit the bag so hard
like it made a pop sound on that bet
because he threw it [__] 100 miles an
hour that the gym stopped where if he
would have hit me in the head with that
I would have been fully concussed yes I
would have been fully concussed and
maybe not have been able to do the
podcast or the podcast would have been
even better because I would do the
podcast with the concussion
let's talk about something else though
yes what about your maneuverability and
your uh agility to get out of that the
last second well he said to me he goes
yo pop you almost got your head knocked
off yeah he said but you move well and
then so I moved out of the way what you
did you went back yeah it didn't look
pretty yeah and I kind of like you yeah
but I mean when I saw that thing coming
at me I was like oh in my head and like
that second I said oh he said left
and I I mean dude did I ever tell you
about the time at the gym when two guys
were sparring
at this gym they're sparring and they're
really going at it right and the one guy
said he came in and he was like uh you
know you have to wear a cup right when
you're sparring at the gym rules and the
guy was like I don't need to wear a cup
I don't need to wear a cup at all and
the guy goes I wear a cup daily Dale you
have to put one I wear one right now you
never know
so we're going in there
I'm watching them I'm just you know I'm
doing like at that point I was doing
like you know boxing but like a girl
like I was doing like aerobics I was
doing like you know like just stepping
in place and I was doing like lower abs
just hitting it still difficult yeah
yeah it's still difficult but even if
you're gonna be punching in a box like a
girl it's still hard to do girl even
when I still continuously most times go
to the girl sections of the gym and it's
still very difficult to even be in the
women's section like if I went to a
Lucio Roberts class right now I can't
necessarily make it to the end it's very
difficult
necessarily yeah I can't make it to the
end 100 guaranteed yeah so whatever
they're sparring and the guy's like I'm
not wearing a cup you know whatever he's
being a bit pompous
and as as we know uh uh in the teachings
of the Catholic Church pride comes
before the fall Jack Nicholson said that
in uh in the movie The Town
um no not the town what was The Departed
um I was like you're quoting the town no
The Departed right and Jack Nicholson
didn't say it a priest said that to Jack
Nicholson
um which he responded with a picture of
a nuns uh he drew a picture of a nun's
[__]
um in the movie so shout out Jack
Nichols shout out Jack Nicholson said
that was Jack Nicklaus yeah shout out
Jack Nicholas shout out Jack Nicholson
Shannon Phil Mickelson shout out
Nicholas Cage shout out Nicholas Cage
shout out cage fighting yes
um so so they're boxing they're sparring
and all of a sudden the guy who's being
pompous you know 20 minutes in goes oh
no oh no
he had gotten hit in the nuts by
accident with like a like a kind of a
uppercut that missed but yeah this is
what got to the nut well no he was so
low
yeah it's like almost not an accident
yeah or something happened where like he
got hit in the nuts which happens which
is why they tell you to wear a cup
especially an amateur sparring you ready
for what happened yeah it hit at the
right I don't know if it was like a
piece of his wrapper's box hit it the
right thing and right spot and split
open his nut sack and one of his
testicles fell out of the sack no no you
you no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no he fell onto the floor
riveting in pain we had he goes he goes
he goes he goes I think one of my balls
fell out I swear
so somebody from the gym called 9-1-1
and then the EMTs came in like they got
there relatively quick came in and had
to strap him up whatever and then what I
heard the gym owner or one of the
managers be like what's going on and
they said yeah he had a his scrotum um
he split it somehow down the middle and
a testicle fell out through his nutsack
yeah so always wear a cup with boxing oh
my God yeah what about the guy that the
guy that hit him I mean he doesn't even
nobody felt terrible for this guy in the
gym I've seen videos on the internet
okay that suggests that balls are really
uh flimsy iron clad oh really yeah you
ever see those videos where I think guys
who want that to happen to them oh right
right yeah yeah and then and then how do
people how does those people exist
they think they just have a different
level of pain threshold I think they
have a different want of but what is the
what is the fetish there like literally
you want to feel like you're going to
throw up and you're in your body's
turned inside out and you're going to be
shaking on the ground like why would you
do that to your testicles and also
there's no way you come back like can
you have children after you
get punched into testicles for 10 years
yeah I think the only way you can't have
children if is if you drink too much
Mountain Dew
not not the testicle I think you would
have a better chance of having kids if
you drank less Mountain Dew but got
kicked in the nuts more I don't know
that because I mean what is a kick in
the nuts gonna do how's it going to stop
you from having kids
same thing about kicking in the vagina
do you think of getting kicked in the
vagina is the same pain threshold yeah
we'll open up Divinity I
yeah like it is painful I've heard some
people say it is as painful or it's at
least it is painful
I doubt if this painful is getting hit
in the nose well because here's the
thing the nuts are hanging outside your
body and the vagina the vaginal lips
have a bit of a cushion yeah so it's
like you're not and you're also kicking
an external you're not the nuts hurt
because they're hanging outside of the
body well they're also they're
completely vulnerable right like I mean
yeah they're hanging outside the body
but they're just like you're punching
the ex you're punching something
specific when you hit a testicle right
you're hitting something very specific
and localized when you hit a vagina
you're basically it's almost like a uh
like like a shock absorption like a
bumper right and then the absorption
just goes through the urethra and the
uterus yes and it spreads out like an
iPhone case exactly like when you drop
it and it depends based off a woman's if
they have what's known as a wide set
vagina wsv right you could punch up and
your hand can actually go up in it and
then it doesn't even hurt at all because
there's no pain sensors in there yes wow
it's like an OtterBox exactly right it
is an OtterBox on the history of uh jock
straps it says it is for women too a
jock strap for the male a gel strap for
the female is that what it is yes that's
what it's called so um is it just like
it hurts like if you're kicking any part
of the body that would get hurt if I
kicked you in your thigh it would hurt
yes so so it's not what if I punched you
in the tits over balls do you think
punching a woman in the boobs is the
same as punching a man in the ball it's
a popular culture I never heard like if
a woman's if a bunch of women are
jumping you hit him right in the tits
yeah I heard that yeah no it doesn't
hurt getting hurt in the boobs doesn't
hurt as much as it would like to get
hurt in the balls yeah interesting you
guys have it a little bit well we
appreciate you saying that men do have
it harder
wow so there's no extra pain because
it's your private area it just plays
like a regular body part yeah so that's
not that's not the same at all you know
what I was thinking before when you said
something it would be actually uh a nice
evolutionary trait or maybe there's a
new surgery Trend to actually be able to
open uh the ball sack like maybe with a
little zip or something like is it like
a little coin purse or whatever you know
what I mean like like almost like you
know just an extra an extra pocket right
well if we're gonna go to if we're gonna
here's a good here's an honest to God
thing if we're gonna go into a
futuristic world of having microchips
planted into us why put it in the wrist
what what is better it's almost as
Evolution design the nutsack to place
the microchip in it's a pouch if we are
we have a pouch like a kangaroo has a
pouch yeah we have a pouch it's a nut
sack that's where I'd like my microchip
yeah implanted the only thing is then
people have to reach and hold on to
their sack and unzip it to get anything
out of it so a lot more men would be
touching this sacks on a regular basis
and then you know what percentage of
people you know I think there'll be more
sacky hands out there right you know
because No One's Gonna like No One's
Gonna use
Purell or anything after they just touch
No One's Gonna use hand sanitizer no no
that's gonna be no that's gonna
normalize sack touching I think we're
gonna normalize nudity um a lot more in
our culture as the years go on I think I
think I think are the children of today
are going to grow up with a more
comfortable nudity level I think we're
getting more and more naked as the years
go on yeah yeah I think because you know
like in Europe
everybody's naked at the beach well it's
just their upbringing right like when
they're little and they're running
around and then they hit like uh 12 and
then they're still running around nobody
tells them to cover up everybody's naked
in Europe all the time at every Beach
right I I you know I can't see it but
it's because it's ingrained but can you
believe it I can believe it okay I see
all right but I can I believe it because
I see it but I can't I can't believe
that that's something I'd ever be
comfortable with it just feels
I'm sorry we were ingrained and I said
this is
this is a private area that only some
people get to see well I've been doing a
hot yoga which they encourage getting
down to as close to nudity as possible
and when you're get more comfortable
just being as close to nude as possible
not fully nude I'm still wearing like
you know bathing suit shorts yeah but
but it went from doing it with a shirt
bathing suit shorts and socks on to to
then removing one sock then another sock
then the shirt and now you just get more
comfortable with nudity
but where are you gonna land are you
gonna land in the banana hammock doing
that
right and who's that for
are you if you go from just shorts to a
banana hammock are you more comfortable
uh well I don't know that I'm more
comfortable but I think you know this is
why women free the nipple I think it's
like well you know because it's really
who decided that the private areas were
private like what is it about a penis
balls a vagina and boobs and nipples
that have to be so private Why can't
your kneecaps be the private thing I
mean there are some cultures that could
be like look at look at this absolute
horror with this kneecaps out yeah I
mean animals don't cover up naked all
the time the only people that have shame
is there any animal that put that does
anything to conceal their privates ever
or that everybody just ass out balls out
all the time every animal I've seen a
monkey in a diaper yeah that's true you
know that's why my daughter my baby
wants to watch on YouTube is that we go
to YouTube and she just puts she goes
monkey diaper monkey diaper and then we
just have to put the monkey in the
diaper on she don't I cancel Disney plus
by the way can I talk to you about
something and I know that they promote
the show but this is like a genuine I
don't even know if they still promote
the show I think they do dude rocket
money is unbelievable yeah I know I I
use it do you use it yeah no dude I'm
the amount of [__] money that the amount
of accounts that I've had open that I
didn't even realize I was paying for or
the amount of like in my household I had
three Amazon Prime accounts I had two
con EDS I'm like what the hell is going
on you did Con Ed was the thing I had
two contacts we had two con EDS yeah and
I had what was the other two who lose
two netflixes yeah yeah I was like what
is going on you saved like literally
hundreds of dollars but now Netflix you
heard what they're doing now no they're
not letting you share anymore if they
find that [__] out you can only watch it
on on one so I guess sharing isn't
caring for Netflix yeah yeah hey Netflix
you don't have enough money yeah you
know
Netflix Netflix I can't share share with
my mom let me remind you Netflix the
wise words of Seneca the ancient Greek
stoic it is not the poor man who has too
little but he who wants too much you're
acting poor Netflix you want too much
you want too much right now okay you're
being corporate douchebags okay you want
too much but therefore you are poor you
are poor it is not I who is poor it is
you who is poor Netflix I'm glad you
said it and we're all thinking it yeah
and you know I'm not uh I'm not crushing
it but I'm not poor yeah because because
I don't want for more other than more
ticket sales and specials and just
overall General inflated ego I want more
egg sandwiches you know yeah I
absolutely uh seriously now this is what
was the word that you just sent
considerably considerably yeah I I post
it I I I uh I mixed up considering and
seriously considerably is also merch
along with
um uh plasticity lacticity and then last
week's uh uh Factory and sat yeah they
won yeah this is the marriage coming I'm
considering a monkey as a pet and I'm
not joking okay so my sister is obsessed
with those like little um you know the
monkeys that play the freaking they run
up and they steal [__] from hey who am I
your sister's ass I banged your sister
Kush
from Tick Tock I wouldn't have guessed
that that was so open-ended
a little DC with your sister
uh I'm considering getting Kuja as a pet
you know if you can make couch smaller
you ever see
alien like that like Mac and Me was it
like a little weird alien like a little
security for my computer it was like I
thought it was a little weird alien
there he is
you can like shrink coush down to like
that size yeah I think he would be fun
so monkey as a pet now what is it I
think you could do it no
I don't I don't think I could do it but
um I think if as long as they don't
throw their [__] at the wall which I
think you can kind of like that I can
deal with that's what my kids do I think
they I think they end up like being
almost like another person in the house
you think they can help out and things
like that I do think that interesting
but what if they bite is it legal to
have a monkey as a pet cannot huh you
can't well they need a large secure
enclosure which can be expensive to
construct
um
they need to spend well that's the thing
they spend time Outdoors like imagine
the backyard in Staten Island if I'm
wrong I don't
like a chimpan oh because a chimp will
rip your face off yeah a chimp does rip
bases yeah you heard about that lady
that you ripped everything she's like
just teeth now walking around she's like
a teeth resting on necklace and do you
feel bad for her do you think it's her
fault into her neck what do you think
it's her fault for inviting the chimp
into her life yeah because she's not her
fault you know what I'm talking about
right because it was like a big story
yeah they unveiled her face and it was
like she's watching now and we know that
she is we know that you are I'm sorry
but you know you want to pull up her
face
I mean I just want to yeah just so the
viewers can say she she had a pet monkey
for a long time and then one day the pet
monkey went ape [__] but a pet chimp not
a monkey a chimp an ape [__]
world of Champs or chimp Empire on
Netflix absolutely not dude it is uh
oh no oh no
oh no
wait which version that is a monkey
though dude that's that's not a person
right there is it is that the chimp that
that's really a person right there no
that's not that one please tell me
that's not that woman
that's horrible wait which but it
doesn't look wait is that her or is that
her that's her this old this is all
different people here
there's a lot of monkeys
all those all different people that got
mauled
it ripped their hands off I wasn't ready
to see that actually yeah that is that's
horrific and I really would like to
start a GoFundMe for her I know I might
be a little late A Little Too Little Too
Late by a chimpanzee and did they put
the chimp down I know we've talked about
this man I wasn't ready to see that that
is that's actually there's nothing it's
horrible watch if you watch the
chimpanzee Empire the thing is like they
have warring Clans they fight with each
other like how humans do at War they
beat they kill the chimpanzee then they
eat them they're like cannibals like
chimpanzees are there maybe would you
know evolve from them maybe we didn't
but but they they are very very very
vicious they eat they'll eat like the
dead chimps they'll eat them just like
as a Fleck so yeah Flex Flex on them wow
weird flex but okay yeah
um I wasn't ready to see that actually
just that kind of just threw me well it
feels so horrible for that woman yeah
it's it's bad oh my God it is I I told
you I saw a chimp on ice skating bubble
I'm not kidding I saw a chimp in on ice
skates with a cowboy hat hop off the
stage and bite bite a chunk of a woman's
thigh off you saw this yeah I I told you
I was going I was up at like Lake George
at my family or something like they told
me that and they had this little like
Cabaret act each night it was the same
[__] guy and I went every day and
watched it and it was just I don't know
how they did afforded this but they had
ice an ice skating rink a little ice
skating rink the stage was as big as
this room right and there was an ice
skating rink on it right and him and his
trainer was
skate around in five foot circles right
every day and then on one of the days
the chimp just launched off the stage
like a midair with a cowboy hat and a
cowboy like sequins vest on with ice
skates and he landed on the woman the
whole table went over he bit our legs
she screamed ah her leg was bleeding the
guy was like oh my God oh my God he got
the chimp they called the whole thing
the ambulance rushed in oh my God I
literally took a chimp chunk bite out of
her now did that woman get AIDS
that's what they say that's how it
started did she start that we stopped
writing to each other years ago yeah
the thighs though speaking of hot ass
thighs exposed look at that we did the
live first ever live stream of taste
buds last night and
Chris you came on as the over sexualized
peanut m m and let me tell you something
right now
originally you were gonna play Papa John
yes and last minute we were like but
Chris would look amazing in heels with
his legs out as yeah and also you have a
way right
you have a feminine sexualized way yes
and boy did you hit a home run you like
that you came on you had the lipstick on
look at those legs now do those v as a
woman are we jelly of these legs or what
do we think of these I don't think not
you but I'm saying like do we are are
these legs like yes no they're like do I
have women's legs that's what I'm asking
you bro those are Gams bro yeah you got
cans
what does Gams mean
subscriptions I have been using rocket
money dude it we talked about it on last
week's pod that wasn't even an ad
genuine truly it's one of the best apps
I think ever created it was formerly
true bill now it's rocket money I first
of all not only did it help me go
through all all my subscriptions and
kind of you know show me like I had two
Amazon accounts I had two Con Ed
accounts all these things save money but
then it tells you you've got two Hulu's
I got two hulos it cuts your it it helps
me come up with a budget and I put in
all this information it gave me a budget
for the month it showed me what my
assets were earning it showed awesome it
literally figured out like it it almost
takes the job away of like a personal
finance person that's it rocker money is
a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors you're spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place it's
amazing three million people use it they
save up to 720 bucks a year it's quick
and easy and uh it also helps you manage
your finances yeah stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe rocketmoney.com
hey babe rocketmoney.com hey babe
rocketmoney.com hey babe you were
telling me that you instilled a new rule
in your household this week and it is
that all of you for three nights a week
have to get together at dinner time and
contribute to cooking the meal together
yes and guess what we use I know what
you use what America's number one meal
Kit Hello fresh that's what we use and
the reason why we use that one
specifically is because yes the food is
nutritious and amazing and cheaper than
going to the grocery store and they have
all different types of recipes and then
all the different types of beautiful
meals but they give the pre-packaged
ingredients so it makes it easy for me
and my family to give our kids little
jobs to say hey babe open up the onions
pre-packaged open up the sauce
prepackaged all we have to do is follow
the simple instructions it makes cooking
fun and family friendly I love it it
takes out the busy work and annoyance of
when you want to cook something it gives
you everything you need so you could
just begin cooking yes it it just
focuses on
expediency and fun and learning yes and
no matter what your lifestyle you always
find delicious recipes recipes on the
hell of recipe recipes they're called
hello fresh appeals well they also have
recipes things that you could do in 20
or 30 minutes it's true and I just
coined that and you know what you're
such a good partner from day one you
take recipes you throw a TM or C on that
you copyright that that's yours for me
that's it there it is talking to people
at better fresh right now hello fresh
hello fresh and here we go right now or
this sorry hello help all you got to do
is go to Hello
fresh.com hey babe16 and use the code
hey babe16 for 16 free meals plus free
shipping okay let me tell that one more
time rocket fresh
hellofresh.com slash hey babe16 use the
code hey babe 16 16 free meals plus free
shipping I mean it is America's number
one meal kit you see why yeah we love it
we love you what's up everybody I got
new fall dates out right now
christycomedy.com I got a brand new
average material I'm filming my special
this year so come see it live if you
can't see it in Atlanta when I do it in
December come these are all on sale now
I believe we got August 18th Atlantic
City New Jersey September 8th Portland
Oregon September 9 Seattle then we got
the theater at MSG on September 23rd
because Radio City September 22nd in New
York is sold out September 30th Vegas
October 21st Hammond Indiana November
2nd PA then we got Detroit Columbus New
Haven Providence we got a bunch of dates
Chris D comedy.com for tikiwickies and
then the special will be in Atlanta will
be in Denver go check it out I
appreciate all the support I love you
what's up guys first things first the
Impractical Jokers cruise is happening
January 22nd to the 26 2024. we are
hosting it with Eric Andre uh there's
gonna be a ton of comics and bands and
DJs it's our fifth one you can get
tickets right now it's 65 sold out uh at
pre-sale so get tickets right now at get
ship faced crews.com you can also enter
to win a free trip and practical jokers
are finishing out the first leg of our
tour now through July all uh dates and
tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com in the coming
weeks we have Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City Nashville uh St Louis and am
I forgetting anything
that's it
[Laughter]
dude that's a great picture
that's just looking
um no yeah again I yeah I wanted to give
him a leg oh it's like that's not slang
she's slowly and methodically revealed
one of those glorious games
baby you got gambling
my I walked in last night because we
posted those pictures you you you're
like you're the best in the business
look it could be a pot that could be the
new name of the pot we got game we got
Cam that is such a funny photo let me
just take a minute we'll go right back
to you but DeRozan deroza as Ronald
McDonald was pure lunacy first of all he
somehow really looks like he looks like
the real Ronald he looks clinically
insane he looks clinically insane he
looks like the actual Ronald I felt like
he was his most himself last night yes
he should walk around like that the
taste buds live between uh Pizza vs
chocolate was unfreaking believable um
to be a part of it was so funny you guys
the the the debates were great the
surprise guest Guy Fieri it was amazing
Guy Fieri came on yeah you were there as
the piano Ari was there
Q was there as a stoner getting high the
entire night yeah Casey was our band
leader he sang a bunch of songs and Ari
was Papa John and Guy Fieri called it it
was just ridiculous it was like a
different event even if like Sal said
even if you're not a fan of uh the taste
buds it's this is like a different
one-off like amazing event it was really
cool and when I walked in when I walked
home last night because I posted some of
these pictures on my Instagram stories I
walked in my dad was staying over was
standing in the kitchen I swear to God
he just looks at me goes when is enough
enough
and then he turned around and started
walking back to the TV because the
Yankees are playing on the west coast
and he goes they're getting clobbered
pressure meds shout out losartan
honestly those four words is just
they're so cutting yeah and then like
four words he said to you and I it
wasn't like one of those things like
what do you mean like I knew exactly
what he was talking about exactly what
he meant and I said nothing and I just
went upstairs you
um you looked so good
and you committed you put on a lipstick
committed [__] m m and you know Ari uh
as Papa John who um
was great and it was uh yeah what time
did you guys go I because I just left
because I could not wear those shoes
anymore so I was like I gotta go home we
finished just short very shortly after
11. you guys hang out after a little bit
he just went right home uh I mean it was
more of like you know Gathering
everything kind of cleaning a little
bullshitting about it but it wasn't like
a hang tank we were here for a good
another half hour 40 minutes yeah yeah
yeah no it was uh it was it was it was
pretty awesome
um and and I gotta be honest with you is
you know the shoes were very
uncomfortable yeah the shoes are very
uncomfortable but but they fit good job
what size were those
wait what so I was half I needed what do
you mean six size is bigger but you
you've no it was smushed in there oh and
I got a close-up of it it looked like
they thought that was on my Instagram
pimp there's a close-up of my feet if
you go to just my page quick I posted an
actual picture
um and you'll see my toes how they're
crunched up all over each other
um and uh yeah there we go so if you oh
I thought just from a glance I thought
they'd fit oh so that's even tougher
look at that you see oh my God look at
and look at my toe next to my big toe is
just smushed over the other toe it was
it was really look at the lines in my
ankles it was 10. oh yeah your heel is
hanging off the bed yes yes the heels
walked in them pretty good I thought
well I gotta be honest with you I
actually felt good in those yesterday
like if if it wasn't for the pain I
wouldn't necessarily be rushing to take
them off if I don't I I kind of get how
guys who are straight and not uh or just
a family's like you know what I like
throwing a pair of high heels in a short
dress once in a while I felt good yeah
yeah yeah yeah Joey kamasa did say uh he
commented happy pride month there you go
which it is which it is and then today
is the first day happy pride month that
is and now babe get out there and suck a
[__] yeah please do do the world of
favor or a vagina yeah or yeah yeah um
I'll tell you this now I know we both
share in common that we don't have hair
on our legs hairless
um I have basically almost nothing left
now my just my top of my legs maybe look
like yeah Bobby Lee's chin a little bit
like a little bit yes yes
but I still have I didn't lose
everything up top now I got I caught
your thighs last night I'm fully and
they are as as bald as your calves Bare
Naked Ladies I have no hair I the only
but you had it but lost it right no I
never even had it you never had it the
only hair I have on my body is I have a
couple of sprouts like Bobby Lee's chin
in between my chest that Sprouts out I
have a little bit of facial hair but my
arms and legs hairless
you've never had hair on your legs from
from when you were younger to right now
never it never came out it never came
out oh that's peculiar my dad too my
dad's got it my dad's got my dad's legs
because they're hairless and so smooth
and because he doesn't really have like
a lot of rigidity and flexibility in
them he's very rigid he doesn't have
flexibility in them anymore my dad looks
like he's wearing prosthetic legs but
they're his actual legs but they look
fake that's fun yeah you should have
them come on in like short shorts and
just walk backwards his diabetes socks
yeah
he wears them all day all right well I'd
love to have your dad on in short shorts
and compression socks he would come on
the next day we my dad would come on and
be a guest why would we not have your
father why have we never had your dad on
the spot he's here for the next three
weeks he would come and do it easily
that's awesome okay you know the next uh
record day yeah it's in nine it's in two
weeks
until July 1st so let's book him as a
guests
Tampa Tony coming up soon as I guess um
but dude that the the the those shoes I
don't know if you if you're have you
ever tried have you ever in your course
of work or whatever just for fun
throwing on a pair of high heels yes
I've been in heels they put me in heels
on the television show I've also been in
heels when I was dressed up as Yolanda
Vega for Halloween right and I gotta be
honest I would never
choose to wear heels and if I was a
woman I would never wear heels
interesting I mean I would never choose
to wear heels maybe I need to spend more
time in them but it just feels sadistic
I don't know what women do I don't know
why they do it they need to look a
little taller I need to add a little sex
appeal you don't need that woman right
you know I'd rather you barefoot
actually interesting yeah wear a pair of
flats I don't care wear a pair of things
to be propped up three inches on your
heel and to and I wonder how many you
have a friend do I have you ever like
sprained an ankle a broken ankle uh from
an errant heel
you have you sprained your ankle I've
got I've had a little sprain for the day
because I've like Twisted a foot yeah
that that's gotta hurt feel goes
somewhere and like uh for sure it's
inevitable word if you're a woman who's
watching if you're a lady who's watching
in the comments on this video obviously
we know that you are and we know ladies
are watching it's not an old male
audience no it yeah no no comment down
below if you've ever had a heel injury
or if especially if you're a woman and
nothing's ever happened to you from a
heel or because I think it's like can
you go back to that hundred percent if
you can or if you think you're a victim
of high heel syndrome which is the
impact that high heels can have on your
feet and body is referred to high heel
syndrome overuse heels individual might
experience anatomical changes to their
legs um they'll have Achilles problems
and if you have think you're a victim of
high heel syndrome go ahead and call
708-799-70 500 and request an
appointment an American surgeons group
how do you become a victim of it
who are you suing the shoes dude what
about celino and Barnes like how the
injury attorney one of them died yeah
and then they just started now they just
and now it's just Selena it's just
Barnes I think it's just
Selena Selena and Son yeah that's my
that was my big idea if I ever got two
dogs I was gonna leave celino that could
be a good thing you could name that your
testicles celino and Barnes oh that's
fun interesting did you why you named it
do you name them my balls yeah I see my
penis Little Italy as a goof okay but
I've never really named I never rename
my balls
um we can name them though yeah I like
celino and Barnes actually it might be
the best one why don't we have a contest
today in your balls yours what do you
think my testicle should be named go
ahead and comment on this video yeah
give us two names of what you think when
you look at me what my testicles should
be named please specify left and right
thank you so in the comments if you've
ever if you're a woman have you ever had
an injury or not injuring heels and then
also please just name his left and right
balls and uh yeah
I would say this is a seafoam
maybe right you know do you know you
know this brand you know this brand they
have those Square backpacks oh yeah for
Joel Robin
thank you guys on how you say it because
I had I looked it up because I was tired
of not knowing okay this is from Sweden
yeah it's spelled f j a with the two
dots over it llra with two dots over it
v-e-n fajal Raven okay you're pretty
close actually what is it I think it's
the all Robin for y'all Robin I don't
think you say the J but those book bags
are and you have one of those book bags
too right yeah I I I I have them you're
big with them I don't have one of those
but I but my lady has one so you might
have seen it in the house
oh is that say feel Robin feel Robin
nah I heard it was Phil Robin what's up
y'all yo what's up y'all
um I I upped my dose today uh two days
yesterday I upped my dose of birth
control birth control arm how to say it
here we go how do you say it fioravan
who the [__] is that guy
like I don't
feel Robin
do you uh do you have ADHD I do have
ADHD and but it's unattended worse it's
not tended to not tended to but I well
it's not tended to I'm trying to be more
present with what I do now to try to
calm my adhds like for example today
what I did is I was down on Bleaker
Street in Manhattan and then I walked
here which is you know I walked almost
across the island of Manhattan about a
mile and a half walk and the with the
sole purpose of to calm my mind down and
keep my put my phone in my book bag
because a lot of times I'm walking
somewhere and I'm using the GPS or I'm
using
um the the phone and I'm texting or I'm
on social media so what I did was I
mapped it out you know on I kind of said
here are the directions here the three
or four turns you need to make keep them
in your mind and just walk I tried to
keep my posture up straight and just
walk and breathe and look around take
time to look up at buildings if I stop
look up baby if I saw something that I
liked I would take a moment and look at
it and just whatever you strolled I was
walking down Mulberry Street like we
this New York City is like such an
amazing there wasn't even that many
people out but it's just like vibrant
even when it's like asleep it's awake
kind of thing you know that it's special
if we are lifelong 45 we've been here
for 40 plus years right and we're still
walking like this place is amazing I
loved it and it doesn't matter I smelled
the dog [__] I smelled the the fish in
Chinatown yeah this is what this
decisions were made I don't even know
what this kid means um this is from Matt
also I wrote I tweeted out to the fans
uh what do you got what do you want the
guys to talk about today and one fan
wrote this let me tell you what does he
mean he wants to talk about Letterman he
wants to talk about my suit well he
wants you to talk about your decisions
about the suit I am assuming oh that
yeah that's from uh I bought that off
the rack at Joseph A Bank in Commack
Long Island I thought that was a bank
for so long yeah and then I found that
it wasn't really yeah I thought it was a
bank uh I mean why wouldn't you I mean
they just go you know I just see the
name Joseph A Bank uh what tell me I'll
tell you about this when you caught the
call that you were going to be on is
Letterman does Letterman mean to you
what it means to me or what it means to
most people is he like in your guys like
the late night God or yes he was he uh
100 one of my biggest regrets in life is
that I I didn't I I wasn't doing stand
up when he's in time to make this I
couldn't get on the show yeah yeah he it
was amazing you know it's interesting
though because it's like Letterman was
like it such like an iconic guy but like
I didn't really you I had five seconds
with him and that was it the whole time
you didn't he didn't come in before and
say hello no no so when he walked over
on camera that's the only interaction
I've ever had and then he walked away
that's it oh which is fine I don't fault
him for that but that's the way
um it was and uh what do you say to you
just that was great thanks I don't even
know like that's the thing like I don't
even remember I remember more speaking
to John Travolta John Travolta talked to
me for like two minutes in The Green
Room uh before what did you talk about
we talked he talked about how he was
flying his plane from there he has like
a 747 he was flying his plane from there
to I think Australia right after that
and I I think I told you the story
before I ever told you what John
Travolta what happened with him with
with Letterman I I might remember I
would have sold this on podcast before
am I right I don't know so so
so when I was I was going up next of
course very nervous I was in a suit
three times two people what do you
thinking yeah honestly I was taking me
through this because I think we've
talked about it but I would really not
because because
you're my buddy and you've been on that
show and that's my dream so I really
want to get because people don't have
these types of experiences right you
know like no one really knows what it's
like standing behind the curtain ready
to go out on national television and
introduced by David Letterman right as a
young comic right is that your first
late night yeah first time ever really
yeah first late night yeah you had how
much material did you have then did you
did were you headlining that was a five
minute set no I had so you gotta let me
know before headlining yeah I had maybe
maybe 20 minutes how did you get that
credit so what happened was is he was
explaining to our fans it's like you
normally so normally so how you get on a
late night set or back then how you
would get on is
either you got so big and popular that
they would you know just find out about
your agent would pitch you but if not
which was my case was not big or popular
they would have showcases at comedy
clubs in New York or L.A sure and and
the David Letterman Booker would be
there watching so one night at the
Carolina Caroline's comedy club which is
now closed but when it was open 10 years
ago shout out Caroline shout out
Carolines oh oh I love the 1975 song oh
Kevin I wait I'm offbeat Caroline
Caroline yes
oh Caroline that's the wrong speaker
Carolina
all right
um so
so um I I was yeah I was the only place
in the beginning that would ever give me
an opportunity was Caroline's comedy
club I would host for them I would you
know that's a ping pong now it's a ping
pong thing but I'm gonna go back and
work there yeah
um uh you know and so they would give me
opportunity right so the David Letterman
showcase is happening which is eight or
nine hand-picked Comics also the
theaters across the [__] Street
theaters right so they come right over
there okay easy so the eight or nine
hand-picked Comics I'm of course not one
of them you know these are bigger name
Comics not one of those guys yet and
then Louis faranda the the booker old
Booker of legendary Booker of Caroline's
I was just there just to watch the
comics I've only been doing comedy two
or three years I was just there and then
Lewis says listen at the end at the end
of this of the the Showcase he goes you
know we're not going to drop checks on
them you know a lot of times in comedy
clubs the bill and it's called the check
spot and when you drop the checks you
know that's typically given to a new
name comic or no name comic like me at
that time and then you just do the
checks yeah you're just a bullet you eat
the the the the basically the the
audience is getting their checks and
then they have a comic up there filling
time but nobody's paying attention to
that comment because they're worried
about splitting the bill and they're mad
that a beer cost but as a young comic
it's not bad because you're learning to
deal with that it's an opportunity to
get on stage that's all I was ever
looking for yeah so the comics go up
and then I'm going up on the check spot
and then Lewis says to me he goes just
do what you would think is your David
Letterman set like you just do five or
six minutes so I was like all right he
was like it's literally zero pressure on
you like you're not a part of the
Showcase but just do it anyway the guys
are here who knows maybe you catch maybe
catch something so I said I didn't know
this story yeah so I went in and I
remember I did not do this bit on
Letterman but I remember at that point
in my comedy I was doing this I kept
doing these bits about my thumbs about
how I had weird thumbs and so I go out
there and I just immediately start
talking about my thumbs
and the check and normally you know when
the check spot when they're not
listening people are just kind of
getting their checking like look at me
he's like what does this guy have to say
about his stuff right right so I start
just talking about my thumb I forget the
bits now I was like how I've you know
born like this and oh I remember that
school pants
and I'm just talking about how my thumbs
are stupid yeah and I wind up babe I
have been having trouble I was having
trouble pooping I was I know we talked
all day about it until I just it
wouldn't it just wouldn't go no matter
what I I I've backed up you're backed up
ripped toilet bowls Off the Wall I just
couldn't poop then you blew out your
Tommy Johns I blew out my Tommy Johns
then seed ds01 daily symbionic came into
my life because they started with the
Pod and they sent us a box yes and
because I love it because it's the
t-shirt that says bacteria bacteria it's
my favorite shirt of all time seeds DSO
one daily symbiotic it literally
literally cleaned me out and took away
all my poop anxiety I've been dropping
double Deuces left and right that's
amazing yeah and you've always that's
what you always wanted yeah it's a
Prebiotic and a probiotic uh and it is
effective it's an effective way to start
supporting your gut microbiome which
ultimately impacts your skin heart and
various other connections within the
body what's that 24 strain broad
spectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated for Digestive gut immunity
yes and additional systemic benefits
yeah uh it's capsule and capsule
protects against stomach acid which is
good digestion enzymes and bile salts
for viability through the digestion
Everybody Poops but make it a good one
with seeds DSO one day have a smooth
soft sausage looking poop that's what
you want start a new healthy habit today
visit seed.com hey babe and use code hey
babe to redeem thirty percent off your
first month of seeds DSO one daily
symbiotic that's seed.com hey babe use
the code hey babe
uh yeah babe I my family my oldest
daughter I don't know were just stopped
speaking English she only speaks Spanish
so the only way came with my daughter is
to speak Spanish how I've been learning
Spanish using that Babylon absolutely
Babble language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions it is
not done by AI or any of this BS real
linguist real linguist 10 minute lessons
I mean 10 minutes and they make it fun
it's not like what we did in high school
or anything you can start having real
conversations as little as three weeks
they uh I mean
you said 14 different languages yes no
you just did it all right well they have
14 different languages
um look if you're going on these are
ways if you want to brush up on what you
learned in the past if you want to learn
something new if you have a friend you
want to communicate with if you're
traveling abroad if you want to land
whether or not if you are going to you
know I don't know what the cleaners
let's say yes and let's say the person
that owns that cleaners is a different
nationality than you and they're always
talking when you're in there and you
want to know if they're talking about
you right you get Babble you go in there
you surprise them and if they're saying
ill will about you you're going to know
about it now and you can get revenge and
that's all only because get them right
back yeah because they got the speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accents you can
really floor these people and what's
going to flow you even more is the
discount
55 off your subscription more than half
all you gotta do is go to Babel that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash hey babe that's
babble.com hey babe 55 off your
subscription Babble language
doing like five six minutes of what was
essentially like improv on my thumbs in
the middle of a check spot I swear to
God three minutes into this check spawn
I get like an actual like applause break
from like and again I forgot the Beats I
hit but I then saw the two Bookers a guy
and a girl Adam and I forgot the other
woman's name they were like fully
looking at me like fully like just
looking at me staring out did you have
enough would could you hide nerves at
that point were you comfortable up there
I I thought what's always been my thing
for summer and I do not know why same
thing when I did David ledman same thing
when I've done anything for whatever
reason when I'm in the moment I have
zero nerves 100 of my nerves are the
moments before and the moments after I
deal with a big emotion but in the
moment for whatever reason I almost
don't feel anything ever it's like a I
don't know why but it's just how I feel
like even when I was playing ball it's
just how I've been but the nerves come
on it's not a great not necessarily the
best thing because when it's over I get
hit hard with an emotional swing but
it's just the way my brain is I I can't
control it so
so I see them look at 20 minutes and you
had to you had to then decide what of
that 20 was your best 506 but then you
went up and just went into thumbs you
abandoned your act and you started
riffing on riffing okay and then I did
like a bit of crowd work and then I may
maybe even I forgot I think I even said
something to the Lettermen people and
again I forget the exact bits but anyway
had a good time my impression of it I
always like hey at least we had like a I
had a that was a good set for a check
spot like you got people to listen Chuck
spot whatever and then I come off stage
and I never this part I never forget
Lewis says you're gonna get on David
Letterman and I was like you know I he
was like you're gonna you're gonna get I
guarantee you get the show and then I
was like I was like uh that'd be sick I
was like I talked about my thumbs up
yeah for real look at it look oh he has
hair I have Goosebumps look at the
Goosebumps oh yeah he does he really
does which is called pilo erection in
the biz I didn't even know that yeah so
so he goes you're gonna get let's get
back to that it goes you're gonna get
Letterman and I was like yeah but I did
five minutes on my thumbs I was cursing
I think I might have even said like
[__] or something like I use like
material that like you cannot say right
that like whatever I said my hands are
[__] something like that and he goes
he goes what all they were looking for
and I didn't know this he goes they were
not judging material tonight they were
just looking for Charisma they were
looking for who was the most charismatic
comic and he was like I guarantee you
had that in space he was like none of
them aren't going to get it I guarantee
you you're the one who gets the call and
I was he was like wait he's like and he
told me he's like I'm not going to
intervene I swear to God my I was
managed by Conan Smith at the time
Shadow cone Smith great guy and so I
told Conan and he goes hey man you never
know you know he goes I'll follow up
with them whatever he told me this at
like this is maybe 9 30 at night he goes
I'll follow up with them I'll talk to
you tomorrow okay cool
10 30 at night an hour later I was down
at the grizzly not the grizzly pair what
was what was the other one on Bleaker
Street
Schultz always used to be yeah no no um
you know what I'm talking about pimpy
it's it's uh
music place right yeah is it the the um
it was like Schultz was always there oh
my God yeah it's right next to on
bleakers but it's a famous music Google
street I meant to say oh not not
McDougall Street On Bleecker Street it's
a famous music place is it the the the
the something room
no no it was like there was like there
was the village underground the Village
Lantern oh the lantern I was at the
Village the Village Lantern sorry the
village okay so I'm at The Village at 10
30. going to do a spot I think I was I
think I was with Akash Singh okay
because it was always used to be Akash
sing and Andrew Schultz were always at
that place he used to like run the room
there and I went down and um and Conan
Smith calls my cell phone he goes hey
they just called me they want to see a
five-minute polish set tomorrow do you
have that like they want to come back
and just watch you he said if he said do
you have any spots and I think at the
time I had no he goes well we're gonna
get you on back on at Caroline's you're
gonna come and do five minutes you can't
do any of that material because it was a
little too edgy but come in and then
Conan was like went over the bits he was
like do the bit about your father do a
bit about your cousin and then you know
at that point he was like do the bit
about you going to England and he was
like that it's like it's all by yeah
biographical you know it's all leaning
in yeah you go start it right now he
goes so I did that night I did
um the Village Lantern I did two spots I
went up to broadwaycon get comedy till
like 3 30 in the morning that night
because I was like just running it woke
up were you like freaking out excited or
freaking out [__] yourself then I
started to get [__] myself because
then I was like I didn't I was didn't
know if I was ready or not yeah and then
so and then so I woke up the next day I
had my job as a physical therapist did
my job and then I went and did the open
mics I went to the laugh Lounge I went
to Broadway Comedy Club I went to
Eastville Comedy Club but it was on East
4th Street and and I went and did all
these open mics paid five dollars did
all these other mics running that set
running I said bombing with it in front
of other Comics or feeling unsure and
then the night came so do it Caroline's
and I just did
that five minute set and it actually I
wound up getting like more laughs that
night than I did the night before so I
was like holy smokes but then holy
smokes is underused and I love it thank
you
I so I said holy smokes and then so I
did that and then you know then Conan is
there all the people are there whatever
and then it was a good set I meet the
Bookers and then they're like great
they're like great job that's what we
needed to see and I was thinking maybe
I'll get booked whatever I didn't get
booked for another two months but they
would continuously come watch me every
week or other week or so because they
want to keep me doing that set and they
were watching me in all these different
environments because again I'm brand
spanking new and then I went it is not
common for someone that's doing mics and
doing comedy for two three is to get on
late night no that's insane so so then
so then I'm doing my five minutes one
night that sat there and watched me at
New York comedy club which is still
there on East 24th Street I'm doing it
there and I bomb like completely like
just bombed the five minutes
for whatever reason and then Conan and I
are talking and you know we're this is
like a couple hours later we're talking
he gets an email he goes look at this
and he shows me he goes book tomorrow
tomorrow night
what did you feel in that exact moment
that that then I started something that
you cry like my first thing is I gotta
go get a suit I gotta go to Joseph A
Bank
the first thing you know I swear to God
the first thing he was like and you're
just like Joseph A Bank no no I
literally said because I did con I think
I believe it was a Tuesday this was a
Monday night I went at like eight
o'clock in the morning sat in traffic on
a Tuesday from Bay I think I was living
in Park Slope Brooklyn at the time I
went from Park Slope Brooklyn all the
way up to Suffolk County Long Island to
go get a suit off the rack it's not a
close to Joseph A Bank at that point my
mother was like you got to go to Joseph
A Bank I have a friend to come back
he's like ask for Joseph himself yeah so
I and the reason why I got the set is
they told me after I've told this part
before the reason why I got the set for
Letterman after failings because they
said they just needed to see me
comfortably fail and then they could be
know that because they had seen me do
well with it they're like we need to see
you do poorly with it so we can
guarantee that's odd because what if you
never bombed and you just crushed they
were like ah we can we gotta see well
well they told me specifically because I
was so brand new that that was like a
requirement that they would have how
does he do in adversity because God
forbid something went South on the show
you had to be able to handle yourself
exactly all right so fast forward Seneca
says the true man is revealed in hard
times yeah just want to throw it out
there and uh I actually just uh Lisa
Toyota Seneca there you go when I grew
up on Seneca Avenue really yeah wow
there it is Vanity is Greek
we all love yogurt
very connected everything you just said
makes sense
um so you're there you show up who goes
with you
so I thought it was me it was me my
girlfriend at the time
um uh uh my father my mother my
stepmother and my boy lukash who's the
Godmother of my child and James Mad Dog
matter he said Luca who came to my pool
party last week and took a shirt off and
is very hairy and is when he got in the
pool my daughter and all her friends
were there and they go ew he looks like
a bear
it's a mad dog and then he won he was
like oh he goes oh Bubba's and he was
just and he just sat in the pool for
most of the day with just his head uh at
the water
we love you
um you you had the [__] you had the
sack yes full circle yes you had the
balls to bring seven people seven five
minutes just he didn't have anything you
want seven people my mom and dad and
stepmom were definitely coming they were
like there was no oh and what year was
this this was 2013. oh and to add to add
even more pressure I forgot about this
part
it's amazing what your brain can do like
you're in such high pressure filled
moments and then time goes by and your
brain doesn't even remember it only now
do I remember this at the time I was
filming a reality show pilot for MTV
that they were and all about my life and
they of course use this Letterman moment
as a moment to film for the reality show
pilot and they filmed with me the entire
time going to the so you went with seven
guests and a film and a film crew from
MTV that's insane and didn't realize how
much unbelievable how much pressure I
was in on that footage yeah I don't have
it personally they have it because but
it's there what was it like when you
called your mom and dad and said I'm
going to be on Letterman tomorrow like
my mom's first I swear well I again I've
said this before but my mom's first
initial thing she said is who is the
other guest and I said yeah and I said
uh John Travolta and then she was like
oh my God and then I heard her you know
call her sisters and her friends and say
immediately she was like oh Chris is
going to be Chris is doing Letterman
tomorrow John Travolta is the guest wow
so it was just all about yourself I get
it yeah yeah yeah and so and so did they
understand the the gravity of this
my father did my father understood like
about like Letterman and how big was his
reaction upon telling him his whole
reaction his whole reaction his whole
thing was always like what he said to me
since I've been a little kid is what you
put into it is what you get out of it
he's like you've been working so hard
you've putting so much into it so this
is what you're now getting out of it
okay so he but he was cool he he was
like he was very calm you know my
everybody else was like a little nervous
but but yeah and then I did it and it
was a nice day you're in your suit I'm
in the little green room yep there's
commotion because it's already hectic
back there right then you got your
parents you got the weight of this thing
on you you got the cameras there they
tap you you go to your mark behind the
curtain okay you're standing there alone
now yes okay what's what are you
thinking behind the curtain alone
moments well my mother was there
actually she was standing with you yeah
yeah she came by yeah so um so so so so
so so I was standing there and this the
sound guy said I'm gonna tap you on your
back shoulder when it's because you
can't hear you told me this you're gonna
ready to go and and I never hear because
I was so nice I kept thinking he was
touching I was like did you just is it
now he's like I will tat and then I was
so nervous about it and I asked him two
or three times in 90 seconds that he was
like you know what I'm gonna gently push
you and then he didn't gently push me
like he pushed me so hard that I thought
my mic dislodged and I was walking out
there very nervous thinking they're not
gonna be able to hear me so when I went
out propped is this a prop they're
getting you off the lab yeah off the lap
yeah okay so when I walked out there
though when I walked out there my right
or left leg I can't forget which one was
Inc was shaking uncontrollable it wasn't
something I I couldn't nerves it was
like the even though I don't get nervous
and it's interesting I clearly was
nervous my brain was making my leg move
but I didn't feel nervous but my leg was
uncontrolled it was like keeping me in
the moment yeah and then I had a set
that I thought was you know pretty good
I liked you that yeah and and I thought
I didn't forget any of the material and
I just did it and before I started it
was over God forbid I forget like oh
yeah what's racing through your mind all
right I'm excited but what are what are
all the like the the doubts right is it
like were you were you just so in the
moment that you didn't have time for
doubt or were you like oh my God like
overthink it like what if I what if I
what if this happens what are the times
I was but but because you don't have the
experience yet right to not feel those
feelings well John Travolta because he
is he was
ended his segment and then there was a
90-second commercial break and he walked
past me because we're all standing in
the same little waiting area and he
walked past me and he was like oh he's
like hey what a beautiful suit that's
what he said and I swear to God my mom
is there I said Joseph A Bank
Gibraltar you're like 79.99 Joseph A
bank and he goes he goes oh what do you
what do you do and I was like oh comedy
I was like I'm Chris and my mom's like
dying I was like this is my mom and
she's like I'm such a fan you know and
so and so um he then out of nowhere I've
told this story before but I'll tell you
again if you haven't heard I don't
remember yeah out of nowhere he puts his
hand on my chest okay and he goes your
heart is beating so fast I was like well
you're [__] me I swear to God he he
he he
he was that far with you he broke
personal space he touched you he didn't
even touch it like that he went like
this I'll never forget he went like this
and he put his hand right on my chest
like this just he went like that and I
was like the hell like I didn't know if
it was like a game
yeah the curtain yeah
and you know like how I swear to God in
my head because you know how guys like
growing up if they went like down you
look they'd be like dude yeah like that
like I thought he was doing that to me
for some reason I was like I'm not gonna
look he's like yeah
what a dick so he puts his hand on my
chest and he's like your heart's beating
so fast and I was like yo it's like
you're John Travolta you just put your
hand on my nipple I really said that to
him and he goes uh he goes why are you
so nervous I was like what's my first
time ever going on national television
and he goes yeah but you've done it
you've done it so many times right and I
was like no no this is my first my first
time however and he was like no but
you've rehearsed the set he was like I
would assume that David Letterman had to
vet you I would assume that all of this
hard work has been done and I was like
yeah he goes so so now you just have to
go live the moment this is the fun part
you did the hard part he said that I
swear to God he goes you did the hard
part and I was like and and it instantly
like calmed whatever pre-nerves I had
and then he said to me I'm gonna watch
you live this moment he's like what a
beautiful thing he goes that he goes he
said to me goes thank you to me he goes
thank you for allowing me to watch a
very special moment in your life he goes
thank you for that he goes you're gonna
you'd be great and then he stands back
and then you know
what was 30 seconds whatever and then
I'm like and then you know I'm waiting
you know waiting he's gonna touch my
shoulder and then I get the push and I
see that he was you know there and I go
out have what I thought was a good set
feel like locked in in the moment you
know the camera guy is a great job
whatever you know they're taking my mic
off and my mom is right there I was like
she was like oh my God Honey's so great
whatever and I was like awesome I was
like where's John and she goes he left
the media I swear to God and then he
walked away and but but he did doesn't
matter he didn't know that you well he
knew your mother was saying that but I
believe that he just did it to calm me
down his job was why would he need to
watch a no-name even more nervous no it
actually I was very calm that's wild
that he did that is a class act right
there yeah that's so cool he didn't need
to take time to do that no and it was it
was yeah it was pretty awesome and he
got you and he he helped your headspace
yeah and then I went down again to the
Village Lantern again through it that
was just my in the suit yeah because
that's what Comics we need to do we need
to knock ourselves down and then I saw
Tracy Morgan coming out of the um Tracy
Morgan Down On Bleecker Street and that
was [__] wild too because he was just
out there just to see him well yeah he
was there and then he was like and you
were in New Jersey I think I was yeah I
was on the Joseph A Bank suit and then
he was just like shut up Justin my
girlfriend at the time was like oh hey
Tracy like you know it's my boyfriend he
just did Letterman and he was like I'm
so proud of you I swear to God he was
like I always knew you had anything I'm
so proud of you but I never met him at
all and he was like I'm so proud of you
and he goes oh look at your girl she got
her toes painted like Skittles
wild moment and then he you know
you know and then so it was like this
yeah it was a crazy thing
oh my god dude yeah funny you just
remind me of one quick thing and I'll
say it really quick There's a comic I'm
not gonna say his name but Tracy Morgan
reminded me of him because
I'll tell you also but anyway I might
have told you this and I might have even
out of them already but I was at the uh
I was at Eastville when it was on third
fourth Fourth Street yeah now it's New
York comedy club yeah yeah and uh I'm
sitting at the bar and he's sitting at
the bar and we're waiting you know
Comics you know waiting to go on and
everything and we're bullshitting and I
he has a a
drink brought over to him by the
bartender right you know we all everyone
you know so I'm sitting there with
[__] and the bartender puts the
drink down
female young girl and she puts it down
and she goes
spits her just goes
spits right in it fully spits out of her
mouth in the drink as a matter of fact
she didn't go push you I guess do you
know when it like you do it slow yeah
she made it all bubbly and full and then
she just let it drop out and she was
like yummy yummy right just as she put
his drink down and then he was like
and just sipped it and kept talking to
me and I was like what the [__] she just
she goes yeah he goes yeah I love it
when she does that
I was like she just spit me a drink he's
like yeah it's great and he just he just
it was like a vodka tonic he just mixed
the straws up and just kept drinking I
was like I I've never seen anything like
this in my entire life how did you
arrive here yeah like how did you broach
the subject could you just spitting in
all my drinks yeah and then she was like
yeah no problem
and then she didn't even hide it like
she just did it at the bar and everyone
I just was like what the hell is this
and he just drank it he just drank it I
wouldn't be able to do that if my own
children spit my drink I'd be like I
can't look at that there's something
about spit spit and feet
[Music]
something about
it
you never see the jackass where they
they put him on the treadmill and then
they put tubes on them and all this
sweat goes
yeah they're drinking the guys
oh my God that guy is disgusting
oh my God
[Laughter]
oh God
I'll almost start right now oh my God
oh it's just coming out it's just coming
out
I almost threw up right now just
thinking of it right before I haven't
seen it this has been hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]